Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
as family compromises we just came to
the community hall in Kensington we're
here with the team mashaallah our vans
here we're going to displace it what you
thought about too brother
Adnan Rashid and chef Muhammad and just
they're here to join us as well so sure
but I've been hidin alhamdulillah Sonic
shares much anything from God or Allah
bless you God why you guys here today
like what's what's going on um there was
a fire last night I was a very big fire
in the Lattimore road area of London yes
many people suffered we know that there
are many victims possibly hundreds of
them a lot of people have become
homeless homeless overnight there are
some casualties unfortunately so we're
trying to help the homeless brothers
have come together they have gathered a
lot of you know necessary stuff for
necessities basic necessities a lot of
donations have been given by kind people
generous people out there so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to
basically help these homeless people as
much as we can within our capacity
that's what we had today chef Malibu's
you're here as well for the same thing
yes as you know recent attacks I've been
hunting in extremist Muslims etc now I'm
sure this is an opportunity for people
to see the real face of Islam and whilst
time is really about because there was a
lady who was saying that it wasn't so
certain Muslim men who came from the
mosque to help her so if you can to
share with us maybe the life of the
false alsalam and how we would be with
the non-muslims etc what is what does
Islam teach us if the true face what
happened a few weeks ago or what's
happened this is the true face of Islam
it was allah said in before our lair -
milania's let me party local official
media report the Bravo supporting him in
a libelous it'll happen also feel that
Allah Allah Allah doesn't forbid you to
be good to the people who didn't attack
you will not violence against Allah to
deal with them in good way and to sue to
deal and as well - in zero to try to
help them as much as you quit and as
well what's up superlime-- to be just as
one with it so it is from Islam to deal
with the people in good way and this did
this fire took place you know just close
to my house and and as well they are
there consider to be our neighbors
that's why we have to be we have to
stand in solidarity with the people and
help the people who are in need and
these are most of the Muslims
they could use which is the local most
of that area the open there the open
they are open for the homeless people to
stay there to settle there until the
till the council I look at the places we
found al-manar Islamic Center they
opened the place for me for everyone
Wow you know for this place to stay in
it with the Muslims or non-muslims to
come there until they are you know the
council will educate them in different
places as we will found as when I
departed they have they done the same so
we could see the Muslims are trying to
be involved with any calamity assets and
that's what the Muslims are and dance -
yeah the lady was making this point that
she was in the building
yes that if it wasn't for young Muslim
men knocking the doors or people waking
them up there would have been a lot more
casualties yes hundreds of more people
would have died last night if it was
some young Muslim Muslim men going
around and waking people up because they
were already awake due to Ramadan as you
know Muslims have to wake up by two
o'clock in the morning to start the fast
yes so they were awake they realized
there was a fire so they went out you
know quite selflessly knocking the doors
of people waking them up so that they
can escape as a fire their life in
danger yes and it'll be getting the
represent and all this has to be I
believe this has to be highlighted by
the global media the international media
just like someone goes and doesn't
attack in the name of our religion you
know you know what's we always for fun
because these attacks that happened a
few days ago yeah these were same
individuals at the time of night prayers
they were killing people and this week
what we would say who's that usually you
should be impressed
however the same thing happened at night
prayer where we showed we saw the real
face of Islam and what they should have
been doing you know this is really
important is when the reason was he
Muslim is not because this is something
every diamond anytime we hear exactly
says we are proud of the same story yes
young Muslims will start to be involved
to help their neighbors to you know help
them to try to make to save their life
that's something we are proud of this is
vicinal - yes the real / young exactly
the reason we're saying this problem
sisters is because we could we have to
highlight this not because Muslims are
doing something that another most
non-muslim wouldn't do but because of
the reason hey that's been going through
many ways we're going to go and do some
work inshallah
so we'll see right soon
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay that's always just to help them
carry some puddin hopefully welcome to
plan what can do now go into a shelter
where individuals those on this play
park just go and talk to them and how
their story of what happened that night
etc I'm totally inshallah and each other
as we're helping people bother which is
obviously important for us not to forget
Allah soprano Vitara those who are not
grateful to the people and up with Arlo
as we're doing our work here as much as
we can but you know those are sometimes
just a reminder for me now let's not
forget the right while soprano vittala
as well as much as we remember the
rights of the people so just put your
mind up and play faster we're going to
go then Shaw and messy web nobody so
when you finish eating after a
recitation of my teachers my parabola
I've been humbled weeded out what shall
our limit each other
probable theme and all summers from
burning them
let's go
okay why are you guys doing in London
we've come from Birmingham and you know
even as far as Birmingham the community
was all really feeling the effects of
the devastation of last night and it's
hard to just sit there and do nothing
so our local community they got some
stuff together in fact they gathered a
in the church and then the people at the
church they wanted somebody to take it
down so so so the charge tapered so the
church send you here
you know no such acts and the community
centers here we gathered the aid for us
this way religion teaches here yeah we
want you to set an example for him so
where we said okay you can advance ways
about this kind of and I'm going to be
conscious and I took an event its
amazement is by Westfield we've got the
secondary one okay for the first one's
jam-packed full really got the food the
water the blanket okay you can't leave
this here so actually we do need it now
we find somewhere there's definitely a
there's a few options
yeah the other one is the full one this
one this is half full but this is a
concentrated on more the children's or
stuff is it clothing which is called a
now it's clothing it's even toy even
reason why were you call that okay
that's good alright let's go and see
where we can find and give it to the
people that need a receipt
bringing give me yourself will stop
throwing at me
there was a
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh